I get it, it's not just emotionalism. I've decided based on the
lives I've lived that I
should separate you two. It's
not a determination that can be overturned by mere talk.
Rentaro, Taro, you're moved.
What should I do? I have to
move my mother's heart right now. I
mean, you've worked so hard, but I'm with you. I
don't want you to have any regrets, so I'm going to change this life.  But I do
n't want to let her
go.I suddenly started to see again, and my tears
washed away the eye drops.
[Music]It
was the first time in about 16 years that my mother, who lost her lover at the age of 13, had a moment of love.
However, it was my mother who once
drowned to the point of blindness and became blind in the face of an impulse that could be called fate, which caused her to suffer from deep regret throughout her life.